how are you guys doing today good good
man how you doing good
good I'm so glad to have you guys here
I'm so glad to talk about code eight cuz
it's just a very interesting story of
how it came to be but before we get into
that can you just sort of give them give
the audience a quick overview of what
Cody is and and what they can expect
from this movie it takes place in a
world where four percent of people have
some kind of abnormal ability but there
are no superheroes no capes most of
these people are just trying to get by
most live under the poverty line and at
its core our movie is about how far
someone will go to save a loved one and
it came from a short do you guys did a
short film that sort of proof of concept
back in 2016 I'm curious that was that
came to be because you guys want to do a
movie together yeah I mean this started
actually way back in 2014
at my I'm sure it started before that
but Robbie and our director Jeff Chan
came over to my apartment in Vancouver
and said you know we have an idea for
something in this genre something that
we would like to something that we like
to build it was a concept I don't even
know it was an outline title yeah no no
and but like would you like to be
involved because we think that there's
going to be a crowdfunding aspect to it
cut to 2015 we launched the IndieGoGo
campaign and it exceeds expectations by
a phenomenal level cut to 20 2015 you
guys shot that Shh I don't need shot the
short yeah and then you know they were
doing it then we perhaps we did it movie
yeah yeah it all just kind of started
because we you know we wanted to work
together and we were steve was supposed
to be in the short and then we had dates
move a little bit and he was shooting
arrow at the time and sun kang who we
were all fans of from fast and furious
came in and helped us out and yeah like
Steve said we just kind of caught fire
we frontpage dread it with the short
yeah and um made fortune yeah over ten
times what we set out to make with the
IndieGoGo campaign which was incredible
I noticed that you're credited on I'm to
be is gee 109 yeah I mean the short
I'm the under
I'm in the I did the voiceover for the
for the dispatcher like the robot like
the the voice from the cop yeah like
yeah yeah well you know a few people
picked you off - yeah I didn't notice I
didn't notice if you do a good robot
voice thank you I think they I think
that was post but yeah yeah well I'm
curious when you were trying to decide
you know what what what the project
would be that you would do together was
there something about the concept or the
idea of code code eight that that you
guys had a conversation where like this
this is this is it this is what we
should be doing together we knew we
wanted to make something that we were
fans of and that was in our wheelhouse
and you know with Steve coming from
arrow and me coming from the Tomorrow
People and the flash and Jeff coming
from he's got to start doing call of
duty short films we just kind of knew
that it was going to be sci-fi it was
going to have some action but we wanted
to ground it and and and keep it as real
as possible also we knew our budget
wasn't going to be you know astronomical
so we needed to keep things as
reasonable as possible practical
yeah practical all I knew was that Robby
and I have because again I couldn't be
as involved in the creative process
certainly except for one thing as I
remember and early draft of the script
where my character didn't have
superpowers but I knew that I wanted to
work with Robby I knew that we had a
very similar taste in in movies when it
comes to this shorted genre and I knew
how highly he spoke of Jeff and and what
Jeff was capable of doing with you know
limited resources and it's interesting
because you it really was a really old
like I said before an old-school
approach where the short was self
financed you did a proof of concept and
from there you fundraise and it sort of
had this DIY spirit to it I'm wondering
how that informed making the movie how
that that sort of spirit of it informed
how you then went on to craft this film
in the end it was interesting making the
short film we shot at over two weekends
in Pasadena and other parts of LA we got
kicked out of Pasadena on one of the
days because we had
big guns the entire well-liked just on
an on the street and we had we had a cop
we were doing it legally but in passing
you have to have two cops and we didn't
know that so we lost half a day filming
on the shore it was a little bit
guerilla style filmmaking because you
know budgetary restrictions with that
being said everybody was there to work
and and cared so much about what we were
doing the robots in the short film are
the visual effects supervisors in green
suits wearing vests and holding guns
like we had everybody that was working
on the project was so invested and that
carried over to the feature in Toronto
we made the movie with friends and
family and the sweat equity in this
movie makes it feel so much bigger and
so much more expensive than it really
was
and even in Toronto we're doing full
guerilla style filming like when you
know when Robbie and I are in a car
having a conversation
Steve's driving I'm driving we've got
we've got we've got camp I mean
everything is not there's no shots of us
like because there's no crane in front
of the car because I'm because I'm
driving and you know we're going through
the streets at night and it's just like
let's let's keep circling and let's keep
just keep going until we find a road
that's gonna work visually and action
fingers crossed action yeah I'm curious
what so that you did the short and it
you got the cut the fundraising together
and then it becomes the the process of
turning it into a feature film I'm
wondering how involved and we're aware
of all the things that were being added
to the story because the short is very
different from the feature film there's
a lot of there's a lot of arcs in the
feature film that that aren't even
touched on in the short I'm wondering
how where you were of how much and why
and when things are being added the
short film was a lot very much a
proof-of-concept like here's the world
and here's proof that we can make
something look good you know if we're
gonna ask people for money
you know they know Steve for marrow they
know me from maybe flash they they don't
know Jeff too well but he had a you know
a little body of work it was easier to
be like here's something to prove to you
guys that you know you're we won't get
all your money away I personally
wouldn't have asked people to support it
if we didn't
the short it's yeah it's really hard you
know you know you don't want to give
money to something and then you end up
seeing it and you're like oh this is
what I invest I didn't give money but as
far as the the the script goes Jeff Chan
and his writing partner Chris par a who
are good friends of ours they you know
Chris really wrote with my and Stevens
voices and and talked to us a lot about
the character and was with us on set
yeah hard time the nice thing about
being on set and shooting this movie
with friends and and you know kind of
being our own boss was being able to
massage and and make these small tweaks
to the scenes on the day and finding
what felt like they served the you know
the movie the best and being nimble on
our feet because again there weren't
there wasn't a lot of room for errors
not it's not like we come to location
it's not what they want let's call it a
day and come back tomorrow no that's not
every day every hour mattered yeah
and the I mean everybody we got really
lucky with the cast but everybody just
really cared you know it's there's a lot
of times in this industry where you get
on a project and there's a lot of people
coasting and that's easy because that
happens with any job anywhere in the
world and with us or we got really lucky
everybody was super invested everybody
really cared about what we were putting
out so since you guys are so we're were
and are so invested in in this project
I'm wondering when you're developing the
characters especially how much is that
character you how much is that something
that you wanted to bring to the
character of Garrett and the character
and your character as well well we
definitely had a lot of freedom to to
make them our own with that said when
you know before we started originally in
the short I have a younger brother and
we talked about keeping that the same
but we ran into a couple problems one
was ours that a child can work yeah
miners and we were gonna we were just
gonna run into into trouble that way the
other thing was we wanted something to
be as relatable as possible and
everybody can imagine how far they would
go to save their mother so Kari match it
takes a lot of boxes for us as far as
you know just the character but also I
watched her audition tape
and she reminded me of my mom which made
my job way easier
character-wise we were just you know we
worked with Chris and with Jeff yeah and
you know you're very lucky because this
doesn't often happen but the first scene
that we shot together was basically the
first time that our characters really
sit down and interact with one another
so I in there in the early portion of
filming I took a lot of my cues off of
off of Robbie as in he was a little bit
more nervous about the situation and new
to the world and so I thought that would
be interesting if I just remain calm hmm
and so I took I took a lot of my cues
from them and of course Kristin and Jeff
and as we were just you're just telling
me off-camera you're wearing the jacket
from the films yeah it's currently
sitting behind me yeah I liked it but we
had to do some we added some stuff we
went back a year later and again to
speak to how invested people were almost
everyone on the crew came back yeah yeah
for one week of like additional stuff
and they got in touch with me they're
like we don't have an extra of the
jacket do you have the jacket I go I
haven't worn a different jacket since
we're at filming I'm I want a new jacket
if we do another one of these because
it's almost jacket vapor at this point
I'm curious because this movie like you
said it's not there's no capes there's
no tights it's a suit
there's superpowers but it's not it's
it's not something pleasant like normal
an interview like this I'd be like oh
which one of these superpowers would you
would you guys like to have but it kind
of in the movie it looks really
unpleasant to have a superpower so I'm
wondering how you guys played that how
you played the idea that in this world
it's not a it's not always a good thing
to have a superpower it's not something
that you particularly want to show is
something you you want people to know
you have yeah I mean that was kind of
when we when we first started talking
about the you know what our our
difference was going to be or our change
or tweak on the genre and I don't know I
I think it's just we always wanted the
sci-fi elements to Fay
into the background and the movie to be
about the characters and the people and
their interactions but above all else
our job is to entertain you so you know
making a character drama is a lot
different than making a character drama
in a size set in a sci-fi world so the
nice thing was we had such an incredible
visual effects company they did the
short film and then they did the feature
and we knew that we were in good hands
and that they would take care of us but
we also knew that we weren't gonna have
this 100 million two hundred million
dollar budget but with that being said
we've kind of seen that so many times
and in all of these movies not that I
don't love them I go see all these
movies but these big citywide
destruction scenes you know all look
kind of similar and I think people are
getting a little numb to them so we want
what we wanted was something that felt
like it could kind of trick your mind a
little bit and and just kind of like I
said fade into the background
Mike my character my character is a TK
yeah and I I thought to myself well it's
not gonna look visually interesting if I
just move something with my mind like
this so I thought well I'll use my hands
but then I thought to myself okay but
just because I'm a telekinetic doesn't
mean that I'm not right or left-handed
so my almost like a boxer my left hand
will be forward in my right hand would
be back and then I just looked at Jeff
and I said don't make me look stupid
he's like no no no no no once we get all
the posts in there and the VFX we're
going to store it and nail all this as
it really it's a big part of being an
actor it's like I promise you will not
look dumb
by the way it's a good thing to say to a
directory it sounds like a joke but
they'll tell you and then you just say
okay
please don't make me look stupid yeah I
say that all the time yeah and I mean it
if this movie doesn't look it I don't
know how to say this without I think I'm
wrong but it looks so much bigger than
you'd think with the budget and the
fundraising that's not a backhanded
compliment and it does because you know
it a lot of people
there are a lot of people that worked in
this movie that could have been doing
other things for more money yeah you had
to do it because you wanted to I might
think of our VFX house play fight yeah
and you know they basically took a year
of their time to do this movie and to
make it look like something that frankly
there's no world that we could afford
not only that they weren't just like
following orders these guys were
creating the robots and creating the
drones and creating the powers and all
of them had their own creative input
into it and that's why I think it looks
so special is you know all of them have
their their DNA DNA in this movie it's
actually then frankly it's the nicest
compliment oh thank you yeah III don't
want to say me be like wow that's really
insulting no I'm curious how deep in the
process you you were aware of what the
visual effects would look like because
the visual effects on this movie like I
said they're really impressive wouldn't
they I think they're called the
guardians there yeah it's just so
satisfying every time it's a dream every
time I was like guess just keep dropping
them from this guy had a good idea the
Guardians dropping out of the drones
because of the short film so we just
knew that it would look like that but a
little bit better and along the way you
know they would share things with us
they'd come to set they'd show us some
temporary stuff but they'd always be
like this is just temporary is just
temporary don't you know it's gonna look
better than this but it would already
look really good when it was 95% temp
don't look too closely like this looks
fantastic I think it was I think it was
your production designer I was reading
an interview him and he said that the
world the way he was told and what he
was thinking is that it's five seconds
into the future it was the phrase he was
using I'm wondering what that meant to
everyone said what the idea of a future
movie it said you know it's it's its
future set it still looks a lot like our
world only what that meant to everyone
on in the production and creative
process well I mean we when we were
talking about it we looked at stuff
that's on the internet now and it feels
futuristic but it's already available
like Boston Dynamics the robotics you
know the the videos of these robots
climbing up stairs and doing backflips
and you're like oh we're dead weird this
is gonna we're already screwed I had
been to Jeff and myself and our camera
operator had been to
CES in Las Vegas and they had a
full-size drone that could carry people
and we were like this looks like you
know this this is tomorrow
mhm and so we just wanted it to feel as
grounded as possible and something that
people felt like could be happening you
know right now just somewhere else I
mean don't you think that a guardian
could exist right now pretty much
already do
don't they have drones and then drop and
it's scary because when you take the
human element out of it it's so
unforgiving if some if a robot is
designed is designed to do something it
will do it with no remorse it just it's
like it's very factual mm-hmm I'm
interested because you mentioned how
this film was shot you know guerilla
style and you were also doing the
fundraising and it's a whole process I'm
wondering if there's any time along the
way that felt like it might not work out
or might not happen or the this thing
that you've been building for so long
made a roadblock where you were like oh
no I wouldn't say that there were any
moments of this isn't gonna happen well
there weren't any moments of of sheer of
sheer panic but at the same time Rob and
I didn't always hug at the end of the
night right because you know it's making
a make doing something with family
working with family as fun as it is
there it also presents a bunch of
challenges right I'm you know I came
from the I came from the world of on
arrow of go go go go go go go even
though theoretically we have more money
to work with and operate with and
despite the fact that despite the fact
that Jeff is working we have different
time constraints use a little bit more
particular than I was used to which is
an excellent quality but I had to catch
myself a few times being like
process but there were no moments no
where there were fires that were being
put out at all times but that's just
that's just metaphorical yeah that's
just that's just the business like you
know when you're not working with a huge
budget a lot of times you can throw
money at things you have a big enough
budget throw some money in it would that
being said big-budget movies run into
problems all the time too
with ours the nice thing was like I mean
I just keep going back to it but
everybody really cared so when there was
a problem there were multiple people who
were on it and trying to figure out ways
ways around it there were no times where
we were like this isn't gonna happen
but with that being said the whole time
we were doing it we thought this is so
cool that we're doing this yeah I
remember going to the production office
for the first time just the production
office I just landed in Toronto I was I
was over in London landing into the
production office and going holy we have
a production yes it's real and people
are working it waited we would look at
look at all the stuff that they pulled
for work oh my god this is actually
happening yeah yeah I'm interested you
mentioned that there's sort of unique
challenges that come with working with
family I'm wondering if that was present
specifically because of the way your two
characters meet the way you interact is
there anything that that from your from
your history of knowing each other your
entire lives that played into playing
two characters that not only just meet
in the movie but they sort of are at
odds for pretty much the entire runtime
I don't I don't think so
it's just we just got we just got you
know having never worked together before
save for that photo we just got you know
I got there two days before we started
production and I you do you just get
dropped into the the meat grinder so to
speak and I've never worked with Robbie
I don't know how he works
I don't know his methodology it turned
out that we're strikingly similar
imagine that and but I mean it's just
it's like anything it doesn't matter if
it's a movie if it's it doesn't matter
it's it's just an interesting you
Challenge I thought what was really nice
too was you know I think that the the
movie is very is very much carried by
our relationship so you know the acting
side of things would be the beginning of
it but the more the characters got to
know each other the more we got to bring
our own relationship into it very much
so yeah and and you pointed to the
picture you guys are no stranger to
superhero properties you no stranger to
these these big IP things I'm wondering
because code eight is so obviously its
own thing I'm wondering what your
thoughts are and the importance of not
only original ideas but original ideas
within the comic book superhero umbrella
and and and why that was important to
you specifically for code eight I loved
seeing you know characters that I've
known my whole life brought to life I
loved seeing the big I piece Batman
you know Marvel movies you name it but
it's really cool to see I remember first
time I saw the John wick trailer and I
was like this looks incredible and just
to be introduced to something new when
you feel like you've seen everything is
really great we were big fans of
Chronicle when it came out which was you
know yeah movie that yeah the superhero
genre and flipped it a little bit so you
know district 9 we we kind of looked at
a lot of these as templates for what we
wanted to make but then we also looked
at movies like heat and you know these
crime dramas to keep things a little
more I guess just grounded as much as we
possibly could this was I mean it
ultimately this is this idea rest with
with Jeff and with Chris but it's their
singular idea I mean Robbie and I might
have had notes I'm sure Robbie was
involved a little bit more in the
creative process than I was just just
because of logistics but you know it's
it's their idea and aside from very you
know surface level things they're not
getting any notes
there's no studio executive there
because there was no studio yeah there's
no network executive there because there
was no network
and obviously I'm a big fan of both
studios and it works but of course but
you know I think that's I think it
breeds something it breeds something
unique and I'm curious because this this
movie has very heavy themes that that
feel very familiar the the entire that
one of the running theme to the movies
you know the oppression of people and
and the sort of class difference is I'm
wondering in the time you guys were
making this short and and then fund
raising and then bring it into the
future were you aware that the themes
are only resonating more more and more
of a time as it went on I mean when we
we never wanted to preach anything but
you know we wanted to make things
relatable and feel real and and and
touched on these problems and and one
thing that we looked at and loved about
the short film was if you read the
comments on YouTube people were arguing
and they weren't arguing angrily at each
other they were just they genuinely had
different thoughts on you know whether
or not my character brought it upon
himself when he threw the brick through
the window you know so we liked that we
wanted that in the movie and we always
talked about how the movie would live in
a gray area and no you know nothing
would be distinctly right or wrong or
black and white we wanted to feel like
life people make bad decisions people
make good decisions people don't agree
with them all the time yeah
people do bad things for the right
reasons and you know it was kind of
about how far this moral compass will go
we as part of the as part of the
IndieGoGo campaign we did Premier's
around the world we did a bunch in North
America we actually we still we had to
do and yeah Dallas Miami because I got
sick on the Presto but then we were over
in London we were over in Australia and
question that I got a bunch because we
would do a Q&A after it is having having
played arrow what does it feel like
playing a bad guy and I would go what do
you mean because again I would just kill
people with arrows kind of like yeah
well
I mean I've you know from my from my
perspective no Garris
it's their their shades of gray yeah
he's playing the hand he was dealt you
know he's not a bad guy
yeah that that's we wanted people to
talk about that in in and you know it's
nice with this this gift-wrap being of
sci-fi mm-hmm
you can kind of hide some serious things
and people won't realize they're talking
about them mm-hmm it's interesting that
you mentioned that you you know you
don't want to be preachy because that is
a line you cry is that something you a
line you have to toe even in your
performances where it's sort of like I
don't want to I don't want to act like
I'm shouting the themes at the audience
is is that something you keep in mind
when you when you're trying to side
house settled to go how big to go well
we were gifted with a nice like great
script from Chris and Jeff I didn't ever
feel like we were being too heavy-handed
and part of that too was going out to
friends and family you know the the
opening of the movie there's a credit
opening credit sequence that is you know
establishes Lincoln City and and gives
you a lot of information and we've you
know Jeff and Stephen and myself and
Chris kind of fought that for a long
time because we didn't feel like we
didn't want to feel like we were spoon
feeding the audience and then after one
of the test screenings we were just kind
of like we need this and then we made it
and we put it in and we were like this
is really smart and we needed this from
the beginning
and it makes so much sense and it kind
of just sets the tone for the entire
movie so specifically your character
because your character is the one that's
in the short is there anything that that
you established in the short that really
made its way into the feature film or
did almost feel like you were slipping
on a new role what between the two
things I mean small similarities just
being you know that this is just a guy
trying to get by and who has just been
kind of metaphorically beaten up and and
you know in in the short he's trying to
help his his younger brother and just
trying to be the man of the house and in
the feature he's trying to help his mom
you know I I think that
I think that he just wanted things to be
easier and I think a lot of people can
look at that and relate to it and can
see themselves just getting pushed to a
certain point that they're willing to
make some poor decisions in the hopes
that it will help them and sometimes
they're selfish and sometimes they're
for other people
gee 109 is Garrett's twin brother the
same voice
Garrett broke bad that's the sequel
that's code nine code 109 I'm wondering
when it comes to Garrett since he's not
in the he's not in the short new you
sort of that they rope him into the
future I'm curious cuz you mentioned how
he's operating in his in this area of
greatness he's not he's not you know
it's not good it's not bad but you do
feel for him I wondering if that's
something because of your past projects
that you you sort of have on hand or is
there anything specifically new that you
brought to Garrett that either surprised
you or was something you haven't tried
before or anything like that no nothing
nothing nothing in particular I am you
know I man I
the closest thing for this to me was was
shooting the the pilot of arrow where
you know I'm I know every nook and
cranny of the script I don't prepare too
much other than knowing every nook and
cranny of the script I didn't really
come in with a predetermined idea as to
as to what I was going to do and again
get got very lucky
just just in so far as a lot of the
stuff that we shot right at the
beginning was stuff that comes very
early in the Garrett Conner narrative
which is really the which is other than
other than Sutcliffe is really the only
person that Garrett interacts with so
know it frankly it was a lot about you
know if you know if
connor is gonna be the is if Carter's
gonna be the rookie then Garrett's gonna
be the veteran amazing so I'm wondering
at this point films Donna if you could
just tell people how they can see it
when it premieres where they can watch
the film everything like that
yeah we're doing screening tonight in
Los Angeles no perfect and the movie
comes out theatrically today in Los
Angeles for the week but it'll come out
in 10 ish major cities yeah it's gonna
come out on December 13th and I'm not
gonna list all the theaters and stuff
like that but Brooklyn New York
Middletown Delaware I'm Canadian
I'm help me I'm so I look at say
Delaware herbing Texas Rochester Hills
Michigan Monroe Washington Spring Hill
Florida
Lakeville Minnesota Homestead Florida
Orlando Florida in Kansas City Missouri
and that's December 13th and on the same
day it will come out everywhere on video
on demand anywhere you can get it iTunes
it's specifically iTunes itunes is
available for pre-order right now mm-hmm
if you don't like the movie Steve will
refund you yep very fair tweet him very
fair and as we wrap up here I would be
remiss if I did not ask about something
that the clutter audience cares about
alone that's the ending of arrow sure
just carry out of it yeah
breaking news for you your show is
ending I am curious what you can say and
what you can say what to expect from the
end of our um well I watched the series
finale last night it's uh couldn't in
the seen that the series finale opens
with is I can't wait for people to see
it so I can talk about how it came to be
mm-hmm but it literally makes your head
go poof like that but for crisis on
Infinite Earths which starts Monday
mm-hmm
at 8/7 central on CW man the first
episode packs a punch and if you're the
second episode is just if you love comic
books you are gonna lose your mind but
it's really big
its ambitious and even though it is a
crisis it's so much fun it really is
parts the first episode not so much but
gets there it get does series finale is
what you showed me
yeah the fight there's a fight scene in
the series finale that is to maybe the
best fight okay so that I can't tell you
but about the series finale is that we
wanted to do a big it's like okay it's
our last kick at the can mm-hmm
let's do the let's do the action
sequence to end all action sequences for
arrow and the coolest thing is that I
want to say every stunt guy more or less
that has ever worked on the show even
guys that are now retired or
coordinating on Supergirl or flash or
legends everybody came out and everybody
sold out in terms of selling what was
happening it was it's a sequence that's
like I showed it to Robbie and he's like
that was incredible I'm like that was
the first third keep watching and it
just goes it's it's um it's a little
superfluous it's a little like you know
it's a little theatrical just in terms
of the amount of people that I murder
it's is what the fans is what the fans
deserved mmm I mean so yeah well thank
you guys for coming in again thank you
I'm very excited for Cody I'm very
excited for ever that's the Seco date
and again thank you for coming in thanks
thank you
amazing